ich werde in eisenstadt bis zum finale
verwalten und einem finalen coni dass
damit eine chance ein okay ja was jung
ich werde ganz im banne das nicht im
bilde
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zu einer zweiten folge von pvp schaut
zusammen mit den simon hey hallo ich bin
ich bin sieben übrig hallo hallo hallo
ja wenn ihr noch nicht kennt das es
simon und wir hatten gestern keine und
pvp chance im monat gepennt keine kommt
dann seid lieb dich einfach lieb sein
weil wir geben uns wirklich was ich
jetzt mache im moment meine pace cap ich
habe jetzt an gemacht so kam beim ersten
mal auch keine facetime weil ich hatte
da kein akku und wir wollten da relativ
spontan aufnehmen und das war relativ
scheiße weil
ja also kannst du brauchst bestimmt drei
stunden zum aufladen
falls nicht ich hab nämlich ein gutes
akku das dauert drei minuten ja ich
werde mir bald eine neue kamera kaufen
übrigens ein friseurtermin musste ich
verlegen weil ich keine zeit hatte man
das alles total schief gelaufen wo
gewährt überhaupt hin setzt jetzt
aussieht mogli aus dem dschungel oder er
ich bin mitglied bin jetzt aufhält er
noch drei games als dritter auf den
kompass dann soll auch das schwert und
dann gehen auf sowie games jo ok und
wohin jetzt um mein gott jetzt wird die
pvp schon gedreht
ja du hast du recht die unkompliziert
jetzt gedreht kommst wie de com ist da
komme
sommer wir dich als special gast
einladen
kommen wir ins special ich ziehe den
rennen vielen spielereien wie lustig das
wäre jetzt einfach ganz spontan dabei
ist ja dann haben wir heute einfach mal
spontan dem komma hd und wie traurig
dass wir jetzt einfach corp kassieren
herr hd immer witze bitte sagt ich sei
das trieb im korb sonst haben wir hätten
ja ich habe den rhein gefieder der kann
einfach jetzt oder iran wird mit so
geschrieben mensch die der
angeschriebenen in iran so erlassen ist
schon mal eine map gehen oder in sondern
joinen die erste kombi kommt haben wir
jetzt kommen doch komme er sagt ich
komme ich komme so gamestar overflow
achter sind auch nächste mal wieder in
sachen so extra damit wir noch mehr
reingehen können so neue also machen
lassen diese sg 31
das ist 30 ha ha ha herumgespielt hier
lukas entlassen lassen einen 30
reingehen welcher stadt
ich mache sogar mit einem sprinter war
ja klar ist doch aufnehmen dann muss
jetzt auf dem ansonsten einfach dabei
ich nehme auch mit auf ganz spontan ihr
seht jetzt hier wieder hinter der kamera
blockte handy reicht so viel sonne des
porsche das ist einfach nur kommen in
einer online müssen einfach mit rein
genau in dem weg zum verweilen ein
mitarbeiter mit ins web geführt wir
nehmen schon auf jan o was passiert denn
was für 14 muss für 14
los machte ich hab mit 14 und dann
wollte 33 doch einfach nur jedes angebot
3 1 erst dann machen dass er alle die
hier drauf sind geht viel schneller
ja das passt schon mehr menschen 12
soweit wir geben es vier alter zum dritt
machen weil wir games 4 0 2
ich habe es ja drei hunden sowie games
auf die heiß gemacht und mein gott ich
bin unter dem dings komme ganz zurück ja
wir haben noch nie schlechte dass dabei
ist läuft mein freund hier lernt man
hier sind wir auf einer seite
ich war einmal war auch das komplette
rennen kaputt geprüft da konnten einfach
durchlaufen
naja dann ich durchgemacht er sieht man
an einer deinen skin mit der maske von
sopran oder minigolf auf ich weiß nicht
was sie gestern gesehen hatte meinen
kopf drauf ich bin heute 80 oder deinen
kopf wo seine dann machen wir dreierteam
so ja ja wir machen dreierteam kommen
dann neben mir saß ich habe dafür bist
du okay auch wenn die mitte und dann
reden wir das haus wieder aktiv sind gut
zwischen uns ist nur ein zaun brennen
das hat er in das haus links von diesen
großen 4 gegen klotz so also diesen
dieses haus da weißt du wo ich den
coaches haben alle schreiben und konya
vorsteht und aber je simon ganz ehrlich
über die leute die können doch
mittlerweile alle deine route geht oft
um noch mal auf der trend zu mir wandern
wenn alle die route gehen laufen er war
in die andere richtung haben da wir
nicht herum
die mitte mai nicht oft auch schon wann
ich habe einstein schwer tagelang
gewonnen ich habe angst ich hab viele
haben geweint wollte dich gerade
umgeschlagen ein konter laufen
ich halte den blick frei kommt ja da lag
ich in dem du mit dem weg frei hält
das ist ja alles einfach die route von
simon jaroslav skach bald ich weiß ich
weiß ich weiß bald auf den weg
ich werd ich habe steiner geil ich auch
dann sind wir ja mal die 2 ich habe gar
nichts jansons gleich sein erstes tor
minecraft fans ein wenig da aber egal
neben dem unterstützer dieses studiums
machen was rät daher die system sound
systems aber hinterher ist doch jetzt
noch was ich es noch einmal haben wir
heute einfach eine stunde gespielt
aufnahmen stunden später ist egal wir
brauchen wir auch noch so auch der wii 2
eisenbahn noch jemand an ihren kommentar
dir der typ hat ein gesteigertes brauch
kommt wären locker bereich habe ich hab
gar nichts na ja die musik dann über
total nett wenn ihr demnächst kainz
kritik aber ich habe ein eine seite habe
ich also herkommen
in eisenstadt kräften konnte kaum laufen
ja ich vielleicht ja aber ich gebe ihr
mit und costa josef fisch will was für
boro es bei der warte kombiniert
rauschen hier ich geb den ich so also
die eier und das gebe ich auch cool
danke mich wunderts ganzen fest immer
noch läuft ist komisch wir für dich zwei
eisenbahnen simon oder doch die haben ja
darfst nur habt bleiben rechten stick
was er hier die aufnahme hier haben wir
nicht aber lasst doch mal dahin gehen
dahin oder in richtung kanada aber ich
meine das ist doch eh schon leergeräumt
eigentlich wird überall errichtung hügel
ja meine building products bei den roman
der kisten drauf ja aber ich glaube nein
als ob also da sind auf jeden fall der
sich einnahmen deutlich dass solche
sprung teile der andreas ist schon alles
gekriegt hier kommt vollkommen einfach
wie ich habe eine bessere note kommt
wegen der um das schaffen viele
volksfeste habe ich nicht mal geschafft
kontakt du kannst immer komm ich habe
fest prozent sowie im spiel
ich musste dann auch schnell daraus
machen so schlimm schlimm
man muss die tröten war ich hab fast
level und dann was ihr das über die
kills hier
ich habe mich fast level wenn das system
versagt das noch da haben wir 110 sie
eine kiste gefunden
es heißt ja schon wenn simon über mein
gott drei reisen schwer tue ich hoffe
reichstein schwerter alt du bist
unnormales conny aber das problem soll
ich jetzt sagen kann ganz offen
wenn man einen stein schwert hat dann
braucht man kein zweites ich weiß aber
ich habe trotzdem 3 ja das ist du kannst
heute ist das dein tag seinen ehrentag
heute ich bin tat sahen o2 direkt
geradeaus richtung bahnhof geht der
andere dir also hier waren uns bisher
luca herr luca das headquarter führt mit
einem schönen leder anzahl das ist
männlich wo seid ihr damit zur heimkehr
hier erst mal schlage ich hab' ich
tausche 2 stein schwerter gegen einen
diamanten
ich hoffe das macht eine das für treue
hass sind auch hier bei der tauschbörse
oder ist er war auch ein bisschen auf
dem seil
mein gott die möchte ich nur bis ich
mich seid ihr mit den toyota
da vorne liegt noch nicht
ich versuche wie lange unterzahl ich
wollte endlich hintergrund habe ich noch
nicht helft ihr jetzt verlauten und ja
ich möchte den türken drauf essen
ungeheuer batman und ich liebe dich egal
wer du bist ja und dabei in der tat bot
den ähnliche richtung sporting dennoch
einer band folgt gefolgt ich hab sogar
reisen schwert alle sehr locker gelaufen
folgt mir einfach ich werde in
eisenstadt bis zum finale verwalten und
einem finalen conti dass damit die
chance das okay ja was jung ich werde
ganz simpel das nicht ist am behindert
ich kann die wahl getöten so nicht meine
freunde ich hab noch einleben scheiße
renn renn renn renn renn
auf ihn drauf da kann ich drauf bin
alles besser und behandelt wird weil ich
bin nimmst die behinderte die genau auf
mich doch nein die betont auch fast tot
es war auf dem weg in die scheiße die
halt die fresse ich bin nicht
unglaublich einfach wegstecken
der eine habe ich gleich ich hab den
typen noch bekommen das ist ein
dreier-team ich mir auch ein team das
auf jeden fall das war's mit der zweiten
zweiten folge mit der und pvp ist an
sich schon wird weiterhin fortgesetzt
bis das megaprojekt in kraft tritt was
will ein megaprojekt laufwerke oder
dürfen haben hängen ist einfach noch
ohne hierbei hinten dran oder es geht
immer schnell zu einer neuen klo runde
health award freuen
ich komme redet einfach so total
belanglos gegen grumme begründet ihren
kunden ein schwaches
das problem ist das problem das problem
ist das kleinkraftrad und da ich konnte
nicht richtig kämpfen weil ich hatte
richtig deuten wir machen jetzt mal ganz
kurzen stopp dann war's das mit der
zweiten folge
und dann machen wir einfach für morgen
noch nicht über brände nehmen wir jetzt
im anschluss auf und dann machen wir das
eben mit simons
richtig da hab verloren okay leute ja
dann achten runde dann wird erwähnt das
finale geht los was zu gucken was das
finale auch an also ich komme manchmal
leisten kann ich nicht annehmen kann ich
mir aber egal ob ihm erzählen also ich
würde sagen ja ja bei uns schon da sind
die nackte wahrheit wir haben verloren
weil wir besser mit ihm game
vielleicht gewinnt ja mein gott was ist
jetzt bei die offenthaler komme wer denn
der typ da ist bei mir nicht der hit bei
mir im boden
drei gebäude ball kommen können wir
nicht sein de wo hängt ja ja meine mich
wird das system bleibt bestehen wird
besteht bleibt einfach so stimmt dass
der typ den weg gibt es die runde
dein ernst heimlich links und youtuber
hier noch gewarnt
dann würde ich sagen jetzt euch gefallen
hat daumen hoch nämlich das motto der
berg ok meine mich jetzt gewarnt jobs an
miami und sollte jetzt habt ihr mein
comcom pvp show ich bin wegen komma hd
gestorben und ich gebe ihm eisenbahnen
ich gebe nichts mehr echt was hätten ja
ein eisenbahn gegeben ich habe ihm
nachdem ich die geduld ihnen getötet hat
seine eisenbahn bekommen durch ihnen
arbeit mehr gegeben
so hat euch gefallen hat trotz des todes
als wenn ich bin ja auch geführt wenn
ein fachmann sieht wie wir fällen
schreibt die kommentare wie meine post
williams freuen ja wie findet ihr das
wir so spontan gast dazu eingeladen
haben hier diesen komischen gommel hier
oder mit zahlungsgarantie macht nicht so
lange her gekommen ist vom nicht
eigentlich stroh dennoch marseille
gewann die top die hände gefesselt
weiter dritte hat man ja gut das ist bis
ist der dritten folge von pvp check bei
der us firma rohde ihr haben wollte und
dann hier schutz von jaja und halte die
folge gerade guckt da läuft kann man
live stream enttäuscht und leistung also
kommt jetzt von hier aus auch max paket
war noch mehr werbung simon live stream
livestream konnte ist auch dabei und
gamma auch fest ich bin ich dabei ja du
bist doch bei uns dabei klingt nicht auf
den leib für mich nicht weil ich bin ich
da nein ich nicht weil ich einfach auf
meinen penis